[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce 7 8 invités
voici les titres nous recevrons sur le
plateau emmanuel vega directeur des
mobilités à saint quentin en yvelines et
nous parlera du tout nouveau système
d'exploitation pour les bus de ski bus
ce système doit permettre d'améliorer la
vie des usagers notamment en donnant de
nombreuses informations sur les
itinéraires et puis le week-end dernier
c'était le téléthon toutes les villes de
l'agglomération de participer à la
manifestation
nous ferons le bilan avec daniel basant
coordinateur départemental yvelines est
et place au bilan ce week end a eu lieu
le téléthon et le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est qu'en ces temps de difficile
les français ont répondu à l'appel plus
de 80 millions de promesses de dons ont
été récoltés
nous recevons ce soir daniel basant avec
qui nous allons faire un point sur
l'événement
bonsoir monsieur bazin mon chien alors
c'était un bon téléthon on va dire très
bon très bon parce que
on a dépassé de très peu mais le chiffre
de l'année dernière à l'arrêt du
compteur du plateau donc maintenant et
ben va remonter tout ce qui est ce qu'on
appelle nous la force tcd manifestation
du terrain et puis le 36 37
qu'ils continuent comme chaque année
jusqu'à la fin du mois c'est à dire les
forces se tait c'est fort se tait c'est
tout ce qui est manifestations sur le
terrain at il donc là on a une certaine
somme mais là-bas pro c1 remonte
progressivement l'actuellement on a
quelques remontées mais c'est des
bridges qui se sont passés dans la
semaine
sans ça les manifestations du week-end
faut encore attendre une bonne nuit
quinze jours quoi huitaine de jours en
vous sentez que les français sont
toujours mobilisés donc avance à se
faire il ya vu encore une grosse
mobilisation on peut dire que même en
temps de crise
le téléthon est toujours présent et
toujours se porte en iran se porte bien
parce que 2008 était une année de crise
le conteur s'arrêter 1,95 million
d'euros donc
l'un sept années 80 donc on peut dire
c'est très bien alors la mobilisation je
veux dire qu' il y avait peut-être une
mobilisation un petit peu réduite
ben cause du plan vigipirate rien
trentin tout ça donc les gens on espère
voir être une pente plutôt 36 37
mais ce qui n'a pas empêché toutes ces
manifestations surtout à saint quentin
en yvelines qui se mobilisaient assez
souvent vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu très belle manifestation je
vais surtout parlé de mon village
d'accueil qui était
montigny-le-bretonneux ou là les
pompiers nous ont rendu un hommage
réellement extraordinaire depuis trente
ans que le téléthon se fait à montigny
renmans a été une très belle très belle
manifestation très bonne chaîne de la
part des pompiers qui ont récolté 3485
euros en allant de casernes en caserne
donc qu'on peut dire que c'est un très
beau chez et il donne sur saint germain
en laye qui est un peu près 3200 et quel
que je crois qu'ils ont récoltés donc on
peut dire que les pompiers sont très
bien mobilisés sur le département cette
année c'est un gros travail en amont non
dans l'est dans les yvelines le téléthon
oui mais on nous est fière d'eux
s'est passé ce week end tout à fait tout
à fait parce que rain man je peux dire
un grand merci à tous nos organisateurs
tous les bénévoles qui ont participé à
faire de ce on va dire de ce week-end un
week-end de fête qui j'avais peur qu'ils
soient gâchés il n'a pas été gâchée
tant mieux c'est par ben vous savez on
peut toujours s'attendre à des problèmes
tant que garde un côté positif ça c'est
très bien tout ce sont des impasses et
très bonne ambiance aussi sur versailles
le pâté
pointer les temps qui est donc tenu par
les durs ans dans café encore 67 mètres
de pathé qui ont été vendus je vais très
bien le pain des gossip c'est un impôt
spécifique pour le téléthon je n'ai pas
eu un mois donc de temps je peux être
pas tu es un bon donc non très bonne
très bonne ambiance on va dire sur
l'ensemble des manifestations il ya une
ambiance extraordinaire rain man nos
bénévoles sans répondre présent à chaque
fois donc pour organiser cette grande de
ce grand week-end est donc bilan positif
pour les personnes qui donnent juste dit
nous l'argent va où exactement
l'argent donc il ya un une partie qui
vint aussi donc aux salaires des
chercheurs 7% et laurence va à la
recherche et à l'aide aux familles ok
très bien je vous remercie et bon
courage pour la suite merci beaucoup et
puis humain de 36 30e peut continuer
jusqu'à la fin du mois eh bien vous avez
entendu n'hésitez pas donner encore et
encore c'est pour aider des frères
français à nous on passe à ce deuxième
sujet ski bus inaugure un tout nouveau
système d'exploitation qui permettra une
totale transparence avec les usagers le
but rendre la vie des utilisateurs
beaucoup plus simple pour en parler avec
nous ce soir emmanuel vega directeur des
mobilités de à saint quentin en yvelines
alors expliquez moi un petit peu c'est
quoi ce nouveau système d'exploitation
alors le système et pour éviter de
jargonner et il est composé en deux
parties importantes
une partie information voyageurs et une
partie exploitation dont ce qui importe
nos téléspectateurs c'est
essentiellement l'information voyageur
donc sur l'information voyageur secours
on a constaté ce qui effectivement l'un
des freins principal usage des
transports en commun c'est effectivement
l'information et notamment l'information
quand il ya des aléas
quant à des difficultés et notamment sur
les temps d'attentes donc ce que l'on a
fait c'est que en partenariat avec le
stif qui est le principal financeur de
ce système on a installé sur 152 points
d'arrêts bien ciblée du réseau avec des
montées relativement importante des
bornes d'information ce qui permet à
l'usager quand ils se présentent à
l'arrêt de bus pas de savoir quand est
ce que le prochain le prochain bus
arrive donc d'avoir une idée un petit
peu du temps d'attentes c'est vraiment
en temps réel c'est en temps réel
effectivement il ya eu une phase de
rodage là depuis septembre mais c'est
l'objectif du système ses dettes en
temps réel et c'est là où est la vraie
valeur ajoutée donc notamment ce qu'on
veut aussi c'est que au delà du temps
réel effectivement deux prochains bus
qui arrive quand on est en situation
dégradée ou en situation de difficulté
sur la ligne au niveau de l'exploitation
puisque tout le système est informatisé
à présent donc permettre effectivement
au système de régulation d'envoyer des
informations dans les bornes pour dire
attention voilà tel ou tel à rennes il
ya une déviation parce que la voirie a
été interrompu pour tel ou tel système
ont dévoilé vie ont dévoilé les voiries
ont dévoilé ligne et à partir de là sur
les bornes d'information voyageurs sont
indiqués en temps réel que l'arrêt n'est
plus desservie ou partaient de ligne
donc on peut mieux gérer finalement les
difficultés qui peuvent se présenter sur
le réseau donc les voyageurs sont au
courant et puis les différents acteurs
il ya le chauffeur de bus puis voilà
alors après il ya tout le volet effet
devoir s à eux qui est l'exploitation
alors juste sur les voyageurs ce qui est
important aussi c'est qu'on a fait un
effort sur le handicap puisque tous les
bus maintenant sont équipées de haut
parleurs ce qui permet d'annoncer
notamment pour des vrais qui
effectivement des difficultés les temps
d'arrêt notamment les non voyants
puisque l'agglomération et fait un gros
effort pour effectivement mettre aux
normes tous les arrêts de bus donc on
poursuit cette politique où
effectivement l'information est aussi
dans les bus et à l'intérieur du bus
comme à l'externe des bus maintenant on
aura une information vocale qui indique
les arrêts dont pour les noms les
non-voyants notamment il ya un usage
plus me voilà c'est une très bonne chose
c'était une attente on avait un système
qui était obsolète depuis
d'année donc il était temps qu'on le
fasse et donc pour l'exploitation en
parallèle effectivement l'ensemble des
feuilles de route des chauffeurs au
départ du dépôt sont maintenant
complètement informatisé on abandonne le
format papier ce qui nous permet de
suivre l'exploitation en temps réel
quand il ya des difficultés même des
questions de sécurité
le chauffeur peut avec un bouton informé
le snarr al ce qui permet effectivement
de mobiliser les forces de lentilles des
questions sécurité en termes
d'exploitation ma de gérer des aléas du
réseau en temps réel puisque tous les
bus sont repérés par gps et s'est
rafraîchi au niveau de la salle de
régulation de ski bus toutes les dix
secondes donc à partir de là on suit
vraiment le réseau de bus seconde par
seconde quasiment aux dizaines de
secondes par dizaines de secondes ce qui
permet effectivement de parer de parer
aux difficultés
c'était une véritable demande des
usagers
la nouvelle fois alors c'est quoi ces
questions sur le retard du bus
oui c'est une vraie attente et ça dans
le plan local de déplacement on avait
ciblé dans notre plan qe2 'feuille de
route' effectivement pluriannuel sur les
transports on avait ciblé que
l'information voyageur était un élément
important et on avait ciblé que
l'information voyageurs en temps réel
est l'un des points sur lesquels on
voulait progresser et le système
d'information voyageurs donc l'on a mis
en place aujourd'hui c'est une des
étapes effectivement de notre plante les
plans d'amélioration du réseau de
transport qu'on avait validé dans le pld
est donc ce système d'exploitation vous
le connaissiez déjà avant ou c'est tout
nouveau ses 50 aux saint quentinois
alors non c'est pas toujours c'est donc
on a travaillé là du point de vue de la
maîtrise d'oeuvre avec ski bus qui a
pris le leader du marché qui est ineo
effectivement et on a pris donc quelque
chose qui est robuste qui est
relativement déployés sur pas mal de
l'opération notamment de province donc
on a pris pas quelque chose d'original
parce que effectivement ça peut
présenter des difficultés
le rodage donc on a été plus loin
notamment on a demandé des
développements sur dix suit sur des
suivis disons de statistiques et de
retour de qualité de service du réseau
de manière à mieux identifier où sont
les dysfonctionnements et de manière à
mieux répondre à l'usagé et à mieux
régler ou si les problèmes qu'on
pourrait avoir sur sur le réseau et donc
là vous êtes vraiment sûr une politique
de dématérialisation complètement
c'est quoi la suite or la suite on
aimerait on va on va lancer une
expérimentation avec le stif sur
saint-quentin donc plutôt en fin d'année
2010 est on va expérimenter une
application smartphone en temps réel qui
serait multimodal donc avec du vélo avec
les parkings relais avec effectivement
les données du us à eux vivent et qui
sont mises en place aujourd'hui par le
réseau stibus le réseau de ferroviaire
et à partir de là on va expérimenter
pendant deux ans une application et si
elle donne des résultats intéressants
le stif reprendra soit la totalité soit
des modules de cette application qui a
été trop rassure l'application que tous
les usagers des transports en commun
connaissant d'ile-de-france qui viennent
à vigo exactement et pour les les
utilisateurs de ce nouveau système
d'exploitation
donc c'est un arrêt de bus qu'on aura
des informations sur internet donc pour
le c'est essentiellement effectivement
dans les bus ou l'information vient en
continu en temps réel et à l'arrêt par
les biais des 158 board où là aussi on a
l'information en temps réel
donc voilà et bien je vous remercie
monsieur vegas immobilier
j'espère que ça va fonctionner
normalement oui ça fonctionne la ra
fonctionne fait en temps réel alors
après ici ou là il peut y avoir quelques
petits soucis mais j'ai plutôt des
retours très positifs depuis quinze
jours disant que ça fonctionne bien mais
bon comme on dit pourvu que ça dure très
bien fait la force de 7,8 et commercy
nous avoir suivis et puis surtout bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]